welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and the falcon in the winter
soldiers shocked us all with new captain
america john walker staining the stars
and stripes of the shield
with blood well shocked most of us there
was that one onlooker grinning like that
kid in the christmas story who gawked at
schwartz's tongue getting frozen to the
pole
as is outrageously the case when men
like walker use disproportionate
responses in public even recorded on
video
according to the latest promo released
by marvel john walker looks like he will
go through a sham of a trial
and then as his name tells us he will
walk the jerk will
get away with it but before we begin
thanks to kiwico for sponsoring today's
video more about them later
so let's look closely at the new footage
in this trailer for the clue signaling
to us what to expect from these final
episodes
i am captain america i know we have to
do
a word of advice then stay the hell out
of my way
we don't want anyone else to get hurt
you don't want to do this
yeah we do lordy so
episode four ended with john walker
losing his partner lamar hoskins battle
star
after carly morgenthau punched him into
a column and then everyone was like uh
oh daddy's pissed
and they took off but walker chased one
flag smasher nico
outside knocking him down with the
shield and then bludgeoning him to death
with it
god i do not care if people would
consider nico and the other flag
smashers terrorists
this was unjustified overkill and if you
disagree and think this was cool
get out now nico was correct in saying
that it wasn't him who killed lamar
but walker might have targeted nico
because nico was one of the guys who
held walker back when all that happened
which rendered walker helpless from
saving lamar
and as we saw from the door melange
walker feeling powerless
is really his rock bottom not to blame
niko at all that's just how walker in
his head might justify it and think
about it especially now that he's juiced
up on super soldier serum that
emasculation
inside him is amplified once again
thanks to kiwiko for sponsoring this
video kiwiko is defining the future of
play by making it engaging enriching and
seriously fun
they create cool hands-on projects and
toys designed to expose kids to concepts
in steam
science technology engineering art and
math each monthly crate is designed by
experts tested by kids and it teaches a
new theme
through hands-on learning and fun they
believe in the concept of small today
big tomorrow
teach kids problem solving on small
projects today and who knows what they
can accomplish in the future because we
know we're gonna need them to fix a lot
of things so this month they sent me a
tinker box to make my own animation
machine
look at this it's this cool old-school
device that can make a horsey galapagos
reverse gallop oh this one's got skills
or
make this bird flap its wings cool huh
and the
scene it comes with goes into detail
about optical illusions and frame rates
and other cool stuff sure this box is
designed for people nine years old and
older but i had a good time with it and
i'm
way older than nine i particularly like
the info about basic animation and
seeing how those concepts come to life
timiko wants kids to be fearless
innovators and design projects to help
them develop that muscle
and you can get 50 off your first month
of any crate by going to kiwico.com
new rockstars linked below in the
description now there has been some
debate over how
exactly nico died like i interpreted the
attack as blows to the chest that
eventually broke the skin
honestly thinking about it this much
grosses me out like i was once a
prospective law student interning with a
state attorney visiting boards and
sitting in a murder trials and i almost
fainted so now i make youtube videos
about king shark ripping people in half
weirdly i can't handle that
but many believe that walker decapitated
nico
pointing to a wide shot in which nico's
chest appears unwounded but in that
horrific montage you can also see a
quick shot of niko's incapacitated face
head and neck still intact ultimately
this is marvel on disney plus folks and
showing a bloody hand falling limp and
captain america's shield smeared in
blood is already
shockingly dark for this universe which
typically only
shows this much blood if it's a bright
alternate color coming from a non-human
like when thor decapitated thanos and in
game and sprayed a bit of that purple
blood on nebula's face
but really i think the implication of
chest blows comes from this moment's
thematic parallels to steve rogers and
tony stark's fight in civil war the two
were similarly ready to kill each other
and
cap raised his shield the same way over
tony's head
tony's eyes filled with terror and cap
brought that shield down but just once
into tony's chest and then catches
himself and stops there he actually
concedes to tony's argument that that
shield doesn't belong to him and he
leaves it behind
really cap's one blow just depowered
tony's armor
ending the fight and allowing both of
them to limp away but still alive by
contrast john walker does the same move
over and over to someone wearing no
armor
and he keeps the shield and this shows
how broken he is up there because you
can imagine saying what i just did what
cap did but it's not about the move
itself it's about
how extreme you go with it see by
titling this episode the whole world is
watching the writers are
deliberately invoking the historic
protest cry echoed throughout the past
year in particular
a movement fighting against police
brutality with similar authorities using
disproportionate responses that end up
killing people of color now within the
mcu it also recalls what okoye and
nikiya told black panther when he was in
a similar situation with claw
hi kumkani elizabeth
and yet t'challa had to stand down but
then walker seems completely oblivious
to why onlookers are staring at him yeah
no kidding the door milaje hate this guy
but arguably the boldest thing about the
way john walker is being written is how
sympathetic the show's writers and
actors made him out to be at first
a camera shy soldier with imposter
syndrome and
sincere love for his wife and his best
friend it'd be one thing to make walker
just a simple monster from the get-go
but
it is important to show that this
darkness can
creep up inside of anyone and this is
why i keep praising the physical
performance of actor wyatt russell who
buries john walker's demons
under john walker's charm and then only
unleashing them in small doses like that
little moment in episode three when he
told cops not to give the suspect a
second to breathe
don't give him a second delete shred or
breathe
and we see this increase scene
throughout episode four like he shows up
unshaven and then he sneaks in various
twitches like when he rubs his forehead
like he has a migraine he spasms his
head to the side he jerks his shoulders
and then even after killing niko his
trigger finger continues to tremble so
that brings us to this latest promo
footage showing him in a
courtroom-looking setting
i am captain america now we could be
looking at the aftermath of episode 4
possibly a funeral service for lamar
hoskins and then maybe followed by a
court-martial for john walker
the one that he presumably walks away
from scot-free because lots of other
footage shows him back on the street no
remorse as he now confronts not just
carly
but also bucky and sam like if walker
would have faced any legal consequences
for the way he killed nico as a
soldier who could say he was carrying
out orders to stop a terrorist group he
likely wouldn't go to any criminal court
but
a military court-martial which has their
own way of doing things and is more
likely to favor a soldier in the line of
duty than would a criminal court jury so
unless walker goes colonel jess up and
breaks during cross-examination
you can't handle the serum there is no
way the us government is gonna bench
their new cap especially now that he
actually has serum in his veins
but maybe with enough public outcry they
could
cave to changing his status and title
away from that of captain america
to the title of u.s agent with a darker
version of his suit and allowing walker
to continue serving his country but
without having to live up to the ideals
set by steve rogers
kind of like state authorities who go
rogue when they're off duty
and don't have to wear their badge that
is an even more terrifying proposition
hey by the way this is our new anarchy
assembled shirt which you can get at
newarkstarsmerch.com and if you've been
following our weekly fitness series
fitness origins the daily workouts that
tommy and i have been doing can be found
on epic hero fitness's youtube channel
those videos aren't there yet they're
working really hard to get them out as
soon as possible and you can watch those
videos and see the proper versions of
these exercises
and you can join us on this journey from
your own home if you like you can also
see all the other bts footage we'll be
posting there a lot of bloopers
so again subscribe to the epic hero
fitness youtube channel follow me on
instagram and twitter at eavos follow
new rockstars and subscribe to new
rockstars here on youtube for breakdowns
of everything marvel thanks for watching
[Music]
bye
you